bonsoir à tous dans l'actualité ce soir
pas de miracle pour l'équipe de france
elle disparaît sans gloire après une
nouvelle défaite 2 1 face à l'afrique du
sud
le match a tourné court après
l'expulsion de yoann gourcuff pour un
coup de coude involontaire
raymond domenech parle de détresse
ambiance règlement de comptes certains
joueurs annoncent un grand déballage
nous entendrons les uns et les autres ce
mondial aura donc été calamiteux de bout
en bout aucune victoire un seul but et
une zizanie affiché au grand jour
laurent blanc doit être désigné nouveau
sélectionneur dans quelques jours que
s'est il passé quelles leçons faut-il
tirer avec nous un champion du monde
emmanuel petit et un grand nom de
l'équipe de france alain giresse
bonsoir à bout deux réactions politiques
aussi et commentaires de passionnés de
football
dans le reste de l'actualité on évoquera
aussi cette tempête politique les
critiques redoublent contre eric woerth
dans l'affairé bettencourt la gauche
parle de république bananière
un face-à-face intense au procès kerviel
daniel bouton l'ancien président de la
société générale évoque un génie
malfaisant et lui demande de reconnaître
qu'il a menti
et puis annecy retenu parmi les trois
villes finalistes pour les jeux
olympiques d'hiver 2018 décision dans un
an
bienvenue dans ce journal personne n'y
croyait vraiment la france a donc laissé
passer sa dernière chance cet après midi
face à l'afrique du sud
nouvelle défaite 2-1 elle quitte le
mondial la tête basse dernière de son
groupe
et une fois encore dans un climat de
crise les images du terrain d'abord avec
christophe du chien larbi de venait de
siffler la fin du bal et pour les bleus
c'était la fin d'un balle perdue
c'était la fin d'une pitoyable aventure
c'était la fin du carnaval des ambitions
c'était la fin d'une équipe les bleus la
coupe du monde qu'on vienne division
c'était aussi la fin de raymond domenech
au poste de sélectionneur
l'équipe de france va revenir avec des
bagages lourds de rancoeur et de rancune
s'est prématurément le retour à la
maison mère comme disait l'autre au
terminus des prétentieux
13h45 avant le coup de grâce les bleus
chantaient la marseillaise comme un seul
homme les anciens et les modernes les
meneurs et des suiveurs les titulaires
et les remplaçants et raymond domenech
en sourcils circonflexes et cravate à
rayures
à moins de croire au miracle la
qualification était moins sûre qu'une
apparitions de bernadette soubirous en
début de rencontre les bleus de gourcuff
nous ont fait croire au développement
durable
une belle occasion pour gignac
malheureusement les mauvaises affaires
reprennent très vite sur un corner c'est
la faillite faillite du gardien hugo
lloris qui loupe sa sortie tu n'as loi
ce qui est le premier but l'afrique du
sud mène 1 0
cinq minutes plus tard les bleus
touchent le fond du fond quand l'arbitré
décide d expulser sévèrement yoann
gourcuff coupable d'avoir levé le coude
un peu au carton rouge
il reste une heure à jouer les bleus
vont boire le calice jusqu'à la lie
justement 36 minutes de jeu c'est la
laigne les sud africains font tourner
les français en bourrique
fl ajoute un deuxième but qui déclenche
une allégresse sud africaine
en deuxième période thierry henry est
entré en jeu pour essayer de réussir sa
sortie c'est sa 123e sélection peut être
la dernière
l'histoire retiendra qu'il n'a pas pu
faire grand chose excepté une main comme
au bon vieux temps sans conséquence
cependant sur le résultat du match
à part ça les bleus vont réussir un
exploit ils vont marquer un but grâce à
florent malouda le seul but tricolore en
trois matches de coupe du monde
un seul petit but de rien du tout a
déclaré aux douaniers avant de rentrer
en france les bleus ont terminé leur
campagne sud-africaine sur une défaite
de buzeins ils ont échoué à l'examen de
la qualification en revanche ils ne
feront pas l'économie d'un examen de
conscience
comment la france finaliste il ya quatre
ans elle perdu son football et ses
illusions
c'est une question qui mérite réponse
alors précisément les premières
réactions maintenant un raymond domenech
sur les nerfs des joueurs qui se
contiennent à peine et jean pierre
escalettes le président de la fédération
qui veut se donner du temps
antoine gaveau mathieu viannay d' un peu
comme une dernière fausse note
fin du match raymond domenech refuse de
serrer la main du sélectionneur
sud-africain dernière seconde en équipe
de france et beaucoup d'énervement comme
en salle de presse juste après à une
question sur ce geste il préfère
répondre sur la fin de la compétition
si vous pensez je suis là pour répondre
à ces questions je dire moi je suis dans
la douleur la détresse la difficulté le
football français
a souffert depuis tous ces jours là
c'est tout ce que vous avez comme
questions à me poser
désolé je
je vais vous laisser on n'est pas dans
le même monde mais le monde des bleus
c'est une défaite de plus une sortie par
la toute petite porte
selon domenech tout le monde est
possible tout le monde doit assumer
on a cette dignité de d'assumer
d'assumer ce qui s'est passé d'assumer
la la déception de tout le monde parce
qu'il va falloir la prendre sur nos
épaules qu'elle agirait franck un petit
mot sur des joueurs dans la zone mixte
peu souhaite s'exprimer à chaud mais
quoi excepté l'ex capitaine et meneur de
la fronde patrice evra on n'est pas
encore à l'heure du bilan je pense qu'on
est à l'heure ce soir du grand pardon à
tous ces milliers de français à qui on a
fait du mal mais en tant que capitaine
ce pardon je voulais le faire hier en
conférence de presse
mon entraîneur me l'a interdit très
critiqué aussi le président de la
fédération française jean-pierre
escalettes il annonce qu'il ne
démissionnera pas je suis aussi d'un
sentiment de
fidélité à mon idéal est de me dire que
je n'ai pas le droit de quitter le
navire h moment lors un navire en
perdition
les joueurs partiront demain d'afrique
du sud ils ont aussi annoncé qu'ils
renonçaient à toutes les primes qu'ils
devaient toucher à la fin de la coupe du
monde et je cite d'autres propos du
capitaine patrice evra ce n'est pas
l'heure des règlements de compte ce
n'est pas le moment de péter les plombs
je lâcherai rien ce soir mais je
parlerai plus tard bonsoir manuel
tissier vous êtes en direct d'afrique du
sud vous avez assisté au match
vous étiez dans les vestiaires on a le
sentiment que la marmite est sur le
point d'exploser
oui tous les journalistes qui sont ici
en salle de presse à côté du stade de
bloemfontein sont un peu sous le choc
des révélations à venir parce que la
plupart des joueurs qui sont passés dans
cette fameuse zone mixte où les joueurs
croiser les journalistes ne sont pas
arrêtés mais ils ont lâché quelques
phrases la tête basse en disant de nous
allons parler c'est le cas notamment de
thierry henry qui a dit j'ai des choses
à dire je parlerai plus tard william
gallas s'est exprimé ainsi on sent
beaucoup de rancoeur beaucoup d'amertume
et beaucoup de choses à dire plus tard
patrice evra vous l'avez dit a révélé
que le coach raymond domenech l'avait
empêché de venir à la conférence de
presse hier il y a eu selon nos
informations un très gros clash
aujourd'hui encore qui a donné lieu à
une vraie révolte une nouvelle révolte
les joueurs ou même par moments certains
menaçaient de ne pas jouer ce match
c'est dire qu'elle paroxysme a atteint
cette crise en équipe de france et il va
y avoir dans les prochains jours comme
vous l'avez dit une cocotte minute qui
risque d'exploser et eric abidal c'est
raymond domenech lui-même qui l'affirmé
eric abidal n'a pas souhaité lui jouer
ce match déclarant qu'il était je cite
vider avant d'entendre emmanuel petit je
voyais secouer la tête avant d'entendre
alain giresse aussi la parole à ceux qui
ont fait des milliers de kilomètres pour
voir ses matches les réactions des
supporters sur place avec dominique
derda et frédéric ranque à la sortie du
stade les sud africains célèbrent la
victoire
les supporters français eux sont dépités
et non pas de mot assez dur pour
l'équipe qu'ils étaient venus encourager
on a vu des joueurs qui marchait qui
pourrait pas on a vu une belle équipe
d'afrique du sud
je les félicite et franchement on faire
autant de kilomètres pour voir des gars
qui ont pas envie de courir c'est
scandaleux on avait une belle équipe
d'afrique du sud une équipe de france
lamentable lamentable y sont ils sont
pas bougé ils ont à l'image des trois
dernières années
on espère que laurent blanc va nous va
nous renouveler tout ça parce que
c'était pitoyable
il faut quand même qu'ils payent qu'ils
oublient qu'ils n'oublient pas qu'ils
jouent pour les grands ports français et
pour la nation et nous on est là on sent
dépensent des sommes phénoménales pour
les cires et faut dire qu'on est quand
même en colère heureusement que malouda
sauver l'honneur mais je repars vraiment
déçu et je ne sais pas si la franchise
et sa place nous maintenons ce qu'on
souhaiterait simplement le lavage
complet renvoyer tout le monde
on va tout le monde à la maison changer
sélectionné à aider de nouveaux chemins
donner la chance à ceux qui sont restés
en france
échanger basse et [ __ ] équipe quoi
excusez moi pour le vocabulaire mais
franchement très déçu pour la plupart
des supporters comme pour l'équipe de
france c'est la fin du voyage de leur
séjour en afrique du sud
ils garderont un goût amer et le
souvenir aussi d'avoir été accueilli à
bras ouverts par les sud africains et
puis nous avons voulu savoir aussi ce
qu'en pensent ces chanteurs ses hommes
d'affaires ces hommes politiques qui se
passionne pour le football et tous ces
anonymes aussi qu'ils se sont retrouvés
devant des écrans géants
comment la france at-elle vécu cette
ultime des routes
loïc de la mornais mattioni veng love
qui avec notre bureau à marseille une
entreprise à la défense la foule au
trocadéro les députés à l'assemblée et
un bar à marseille
petit tour de souffrance des
téléspectateurs français
16h20 trocadéro l'abattement après le
premier but sud africain
vivement la fin
16h26 la défense la malédiction
après l'élimination de gourcuff je suis
désabusé j'ai tout donné sur les deux
autres matches là j'étais encore à
monter avec un petit pas d'espoir mais
là là j'avoue c'est rôle 16h37 trocadéro
la consternation après le deuxième but
sud africain
une partie du public se lève et s'en va
16h43 marseille joie d'offrir plaisir de
recevoir la france manque d'encaisser un
troisième but
je pense qu'on l'homme devra alors lancé
des tomates et des jeux ce que l'on
faisait traditionnellement dans le passé
fin de la mi-temps trocadéro retour vers
l'enfer le match reprend on mouille pas
le maillot vraiment notre âge on joue
mieux que qu'est ce que vous voulez
17h25 domicile parisien de jean claude
darmon l'homme d'affaires du foot
français
seul et unique but tricolore un sursaut
vers l'honneur encore un but
17h45 assemblée nationale et élimination
comme si les députés voter une motion de
censure au bleu toyer les écuries
d'augias et faire en sorte que la
gouvernance de l'équipe de france à
travers danses de la fédération
l'entraîneur est capital d'adp équipe de
france a complètement revu et qu'enfin
ya des gens qui dirigent
c'est tous les excès notre société c'est
l'argent l'individualisme tellement
qu'est ce que c'est qu'une équipe de
france si ce n'est une équipe de traders
dont on ne se rend plus compte en son
sein de ce qui est autorisé ce qui ne
l'est pas ce soir l'équipe a viré au
bleu sombre et n'importe plus qu'un seul
rêve passer vite à autre chose merci
d'être avec nous et emmanuel petit
champion du monde en 1998
que retenez-vous de cette dernière
journée ratée comme les autres normes
déception une libération
pourquoi une libération enfin c'est
terminé à ce point l'arrêt vous êtes
soulagés soulagé parce que on a montré
un visage non seulement sur le terrain
et en dehors extrêmement pitoyable
indigne aucune dignité donc j'avais hâte
que ça se termine mais en tant qu'ancien
bleus ont tant qu'ancien international
est encore plus peut-être en tant que
champion du monde vous le ressentez
particulièrement
oui ça nous touche parce que ça soit
notre génération celle d'avant
d'ailleurs alain je pense qu'il va
donner son avis également mais ça soit
la génération des raymond kopa des
michel platini autres il y avait une
espèce de tradition comme un passage de
relais avec le sentiment à chaque fois
qu'on devait apprendre du passé pour
essayer d'apporter mais aussi notre car
l'édifice
aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression c'est un
champ de ruines à tous les niveaux qu'il
ya plus de valeur qu on est très très
loin de ce que
que le sport est en jeu c'est ça qui
vous choque d'abord c'est l'impression
qui a plus de valeur c'est à dire
l'amour du maillot l'engagement
collectif il faut pas fermer un amalgame
non plus mais je pense qu'il ya quand
même des joueurs qui d'une façon
générale ils ont l'honneur de porter le
maillot mais on l'a très peu vu
je crois que ce que l'on a vu au sein de
la fédération mais aussi au niveau des
joueurs aujourd'hui c'est vrai que la
notion de valeur et d'honneur de porter
un maillot l'identité nationale c'est
vrai qu'on n'a pas beaucoup vu alain
giresse vous êtes avec nous en direct
d'afrique du sud merci pour cela est ce
que vous pensiez vous que au vu de ce
qui s'était passé en dehors du terrain
l'équipe pouvait vraiment arriver à se
motiver à se concentrer pour arriver à
un résultat aujourd'hui où vous pensiez
que c'était déjà mort non il ya une
justice dans le dans le football on peut
pas tricher
pourquoi pas tricher avec le football et
et ce soir c'est la triste conclusion
d'une coupe du monde qui a été
galvaudé négligé depuis le depuis le
début on a on sait on s'est vautré dans
les déclarations comme si on donnait
l'illusion que tout allait bien et on
sait masqué de la réalité
maintenant c'est triste c'est ça fait
mal et emmanuel dadis était c'était on
est soulagé que ce soit malheureusement
terminée quand on voit dans quel état
l'équipe de france ça ça fait du mal
c'est ce qui s'est passé hors du terrain
où ce qui s'est passé sur le terrain qui
vous déçoit le plus c'est ce qui s'est
passé sur le terrain ce n'est que la
suite logique des événements hors du
dehors du terrain comment on peut
comment peut négliger le terrain comment
on peut le mettre de côté en nous volant
passent entraîner des problèmes dans des
équipes y en a on peut les régler on
peut faire face à tous et à toutes ces
que ces problèmes mais mais quand même
oublier que là on est là on est un
joueur football ce qui compte avant tout
c'est le match c'est l'intérêt du jeu on
l'a complètement mis de côté et volé
vous derrière après aller chercher un
résultat une qualification
non on n'est pas dans la logique du du
football et aujourd'hui les joueurs
français n'ont eu que ce qu'il méritait
alors avant d'aller plus loin justement
je voudrais qu'on revienne sur ce qui a
été non seulement un désastre sportif
mais aussi morale voici les onze petites
phrases 11 comme le nombre de joueurs
d'une équipe qui ont marqué cette
spirale de l'échec
grégory naboulet ce n'était pas encore
le début du mondial et c'était déjà le
début de la fin le 19 novembre 2009
thiery henry revisite la main de dieu et
qualifie les bleus pour l'afrique du sud
laissez moi le bonheur simplement et
partager ce bonheur et tous les gens qui
sont contents que l'équipe de france
soit qualifiée et y en a avant de partir
l'image des bleus étaient déjà écornée
ce qui suit est bien pire et tient en
quelques mots prononcés le mardi 12 mai
2010 lorsque raymond domenech annonce sa
sélection pour le mondial j'espère
qu'ils me font rire personne pendant
cette coupe du monde en afrique du sud
l'équipe de france se renferme sur
elle-même le pays critiquent son jeu et
son hôtel de luxe
nous sommes le jeudi 10 juin à la veille
du premier match contre l'uruguay on
vient vraiment ici pour aller jusqu'au
bout après dans le football tout peut
arriver
un seuil de résistance à la pression qui
fait que
voilà moi j'ai calculé normalement mon
seuil de résistance il va jusqu'au 12
juillet après je brûle
mercredi 16 juin 2010 après france
uruguay les supporters sont sceptiques
les bleus font semblant d'y croire c'est
vraiment jeudi un groupe vraiment soudée
et je le dis pas pour faire plaisir aux
journalistes c'est vraiment la réalité
après je vous dis célestine qui trompe
pas et c'est pour ça que je me dis cette
équipe sera solide jusqu'au bout jeudi
17 juin 30,0 mexique 2 les bleus
touchent le fond problème c'est
c'est qu'on n'a pas une grande équipe je
je trouve des mots pour bath qui reste
un match ce soir là raymond domenech a
perdu bien plus qu'un match il a perdu
ce qui lui reste et d'autorité dans le
vestiaire nicolas anelka la même insulté
samedi 19 juin anelka et exclu des kits
de france le problème de l'équipe de
france n'est pas anelka c'est le traître
qui est parmi nous ce que vous le dire
comment cette chose a pu sortir dimanche
20 juin les bleus font la grève de
l'entraînement je considère que ce qui
se passe cet après midi un scandale
vraiment mal pour les français
un scandale pour les jeunes qui sont ici
un scandale pour la fédération et pour
l'équipe de ces conditions c'est par ce
communiqué tous les joueurs de l'équipe
de france sans exception souhaitent
affirmer leur opposition à la décision
prise par la fédération française de
football exclut d'exclure nicolas anelka
aujourd'hui les bleus ont mis fin à
trois semaines de petites phrases de
grands mots et de résultats
catastrophiques
emmanuel petit un groupe qui implosent à
ce point dans votre carrière à ce que
vous avez déjà vu ça et pour vous qui
est responsable sont d'abord les joueurs
cette génération où l'entraîneur les
joueurs sont responsables
jusqu'à une certaine mesure je pense que
ce qu'ils ont montré c'est indigne mais
il se la responsabilité faut pas non
plus occulter sur leurs prestations
sportives la responsabilité allait bien
en amont aller au niveau fédéral du
système fédéral du conseil fédéral je
crois qu'il ya des gens depuis très
longtemps qui se fiche de ce que je
pense le monde professionnel en règle
générale donc c'est ça à mon avis il
faut que ces personnes là prennent leurs
responsabilités aujourd'hui donc vous
souhaitez par exemple que jean pierre
escalettes démissionne ça vous
semblerait normal lui apparemment il n'a
pas le sentiment de reconnaissance
responsabilités je continue il veut pas
quitter le navire
moi je pense que qu'ils aient au moins
la décence surtout l'honnêteté
intellectuelle de reconnaître leur
responsabilité qui dure depuis un petit
moment déjà
même sentiment alain giresse un
supporters tout à l'heure on entendait
parler d'un grand coup de balai
nécessaire c'est pour vous aussi une
nécessité que les responsables assument
leurs responsabilités
d'une part et yvan tout le monde tout le
monde est responsable ce n'est pas que
les joueurs pour le taf c'est tout le
monde qui est responsable et 2 de ce
désastre et surtout maintenant se
projeter sur l'avenir c'est si rob a pu
repartir de zéro étonné donner les
moyens à laurent blanc justement
d'imprimer une nouvelle dynamique à
cette équipe et kanak grand besoin et en
fixant des règles strictes et et
draconiennes sinon si l'on enlève on
part vraiment dans tant de temps
et dans des crises et qui se rendront
compte et qui vont durer laurent blanc
doit être nommé sélectionneur dans
quelques jours vous qui est aussi
entraîneur alain giresse que feriez vous
à sa place qu'elles sont là où les deux
ou trois premières décisions qu'ils
doivent prendre mais d'abord c'est
d'avoir toutes les garanties d'avoir
tout loisir la mainmise entière et
totale sur l'organisation la mise en
place du fonctionnement de l'équipe de
france ça c'est la première nécessité
c'est lui qui doit dicter comment va
fonctionner cette équipe comment il va
la mettra en oeuvre parce que c'est lui
qui arrive avec ce côté n'être qu'il a
il auréolé de bons résultats avec avec
le riz bordeaux et policiers les clés de
la maison entièrement et totalement s'il
ya quelques réticences du côté là si on
veut s'immiscer dans son travail c'est
même pas la peine qu'il est marc
emmanuel petit est ce que cette coupe du
monde marquent la fin pour certains
joueurs qui sont pas forcément touché
par l'âge mais qui se sont discrédités
d'après vous non parce qu'il faut quand
même relativiser aussi je veux dire il y
en a beaucoup qui ont une grande
carrière derrière eux donc il ya
probablement des joueurs qui sont en fin
de carrière avec l'équipe de france mais
laurent blanc il va il va devoir
justement faire avec l'ensemble des
joueurs qui sont qui sont présents
aujourd'hui à la coupe du monde donc
avec une dizaine voire une vingtaine de
joueurs qui sont aujourd'hui
sélectionnable donc ça sera propre
probablement les mêmes joueurs il doit
garder l'essentiel de l'équipe d'après
vous non il faut qu'ils instaurent un
nouvel état d'esprit je suis
complètement d'accord avec alain quand
il dit qu il faut dans le projet sportif
qui va intégrer sur les deux années qui
est devant lui il faut absolument qu'on
lui donne la capacité de mettre en place
les choses sans interférence aujourd'hui
l'équipe de france est sur le chemin de
la rédemption donc ça va être long parce
que en dehors des ddd résultats sportifs
sur le tard il va falloir aussi
travailler l'image faire revenir les
annonceurs donc c'est tout un chantier
qu'il faut reconstruire une charte de
déontologie comme l'évoquent la ministre
des sports roselyne bachelot par exemple
pour les joueurs ça rime à quelque chose
ou à rien selon moi j'irai encore plus
loin aujourd'hui l'uefa michel platini
prône pour le fair play financier pour
remettre une certaine équité sportive à
travers les championnats respectifs moi
je pense qu'il faut également faire un
fair-play morale où on peut sanctionner
non financièrement but plus sportivement
ce soit des joueurs des fédérations voir
des clubs à travers des comportements
qui sont respectueux voire immoraux
merci emmanuel petit de nous avoir donné
votre sentiment ce soir merci à vous
aussi alain giresse on va vous retrouver
sur france 2 dans quelques instants pour
les autres matches une image des deux
équipes de ce groupe à qui se sont
qualifiés pour les huitièmes de finale
c'était
thaler l'uruguay a battu le mexique 1 0
but ici signés suarez mais les deux
équipes sont donc qualifiés dans le
reste de l'actualité la tempête
politique je vous le disais autour du
cas d'eric woerth la démission de son
épouse hier n'a pas calmé les esprits la
gauche accuse de conflit d'intérêt dans
l'affairé bettencourt le ministre lui
les nonces d attaque immonde c'est son
terme tiré curtet dominique bonnet le
cas eric woerth a largement débordé les
murs de l'assemblée ce matin à gauche
les francs-tireurs demandait que le
ministre se met à la disposition de la
justice pendant que monsieur woerth
demande aux français des efforts
supplémentaires veut enlever la retraite
à 60 ans aux gens qui travaillent dur
lui même fréquentes en quelque sorte
d'une espèce de mélange des genres les
grandes fortunes et les hauts
patrimoines dans l'hémicycle c'est
françois fillon qui choisit de répondre
à la place de l'actuel ministre du
travail est le premier ministre hausse
le ton eric woerth n'a commis aucune
faute
eric woerth n'a donné aucune instruction
concernant la situation fiscale de
madame pose en vrai eric woerth a toute
ma confiance et j'ajoute aujourd'hui
devant vous toute mon amitié
eric woerth prend ensuite la parole
voulez je vous dise monsieur le député
ce que je pense de tout cela remet cette
immonde et cette ignoble
jamais jamais mon épouse n'a eu besoin
de moi pour trouver un travail pour la
majorité des socialistes il n'y a pas
forcément d'affaires eric woerth mais un
problème de mélange des genres
il a en effet cumulé la fonction de
ministre du budget et de trésorier de
l'union une image encore à propos de
politique image symbolique qui ne doit
rien au hasard nicolas sarkozy
inaugurait aujourd'hui une usine
turbomeca dans le béarn dans la
circonscription de françois bayrou et
les deux hommes vous le voyez étaient
côte à côte
le chef de l'état a vanté à cette
occasion les bienfaits je cite une
france rassemblée nous parler nous
écouter sans que personne ne renonce à
ses cris
fiction la mesure n'aura échappé à
personne françois bayrou lui à nier tout
réchauffement politique avec le
président de la république la justice en
bref avec un temps fort au procès de
jérôme kerviel l'ancien pdg de la
société générale son employeur daniel
bouton était à la barre et il a évoqué
je cite le génie malfaisant de l'ancien
trader
il m'arrive d'avoir un rêve at il lancé
que jérôme kerviel reconnaisse qu'il a
menti et qu'il a fait cela tout seul
jérôme kerviel qui a maintenu lui que
ses supérieurs ne pouvait ignorer ses
agissements images signées zidène
berkous à l'étranger l'attend en
afghanistan hervé morin ministre de la
défense et patrick de carolis le
président de france télévisions sont
retournés sur place
il ya cent soixante quinze jours
maintenant que stéphane taponier et
hervé ghesquière ont été enlevés
hervé morin indique qu'il attend une
preuve de vie des deux journalistes la
dernière remonte au mois d'avril
depuis il n'y a eu que des contacts
indirects avec les ravisseurs
et puis encore un mode sport mais ça
n'est pas du football
annecy fait partie des trois villes
retenues avec munich en allemagne et
pyeongchang en corée du sud pour les
jeux d'hiver 2018
en revanche le comité olympique demande
un regroupement des sites de choix aura
lieu dans un an tout de suite retour au
football la coupe du monde continue même
sens la france avec une soirée décisive
dans le groupe b grèce argentine nigeria
corée du sud c'est le programme ce soir
avec laurent luyat et emmanuel petit
qu'on vient de libérer merci à vous à
demain
l'info en continu et aussi sur france 2
point fr